Brad Pitt merci
voici une chose que vous n'entendez jamais après avoir
visionné un film de David Fincher
qui était amusant nous aurions dû amener les
enfants
non
oui j'ai joué un rôle dans trois des
films de David Fincher
salut je m'appelle Brad Pitt et je suis un
survivant
voici  certaines choses que vous pourriez entendre sur un plateau de
David Fincher,
tournons ceci s'il vous plaît avant que nous
perdions tous intérêt à vivre
d'accord, nous avons la version floue
essayons-en une qui est nette
si vous faites un panoramique vers la droite et voyez que dans
votre cadre à nouveau vous avez  ma permission
de vous suicider
et un favori personnel je veux que vous
vous amusiez mais c'est ce que sont
les samedis et les dimanches car
personne ne dit que faire un film d'aventure est
facile tous vous diront que ça vaut le coup
certains disent que c'est un perfectionniste c'est
vrai très  vrai, la
rumeur dit qu'il a une fois tourné 90 prend une
seule configuration c'est entièrement faux c'est
inexact ce n'est pas vrai c'était 92.
il a dit qu'un directeur de studio l'a approché
après une projection en disant
David je ne suis pas à l'aise avec cette coupe la
réponse de David était que tu as mon
sympathie
c'est vrai c'est vrai apparemment pendant le
tournage de la naissance de sa fille, il
a demandé au médecin s'il pouvait réessayer celui-
là
qui n'est pas fondé je ne suis pas sûr
euh
si vous pouvez dire maintenant que j'aime le groupe
de tout mon cœur et je suis  ravi de
pouvoir lui tendre une embuscade ici aujourd'hui et de faire
partie de l'honneur de l'un de nos plus grands
conteurs
et félicitations pour l'avoir même amené ici
pour cet homme qui est plus enclin à éviter
les projecteurs
pour David, c'est imaginer que c'est l'
imagination de l'idée quand il est le plus heureux
Le  Innovation la psychologie de la
chose qu'il peut déterrer au moment où il
commence à tourner, il vous dira que c'est
le moment où il commence à ne pas atteindre
ses aspirations
et alors l'agonie commence,
d'autres réalisateurs essaient souvent de l'imiter
mais échouent invariablement parce qu'ils  pense que
c'est juste à propos de l'imagerie
mais si c'était juste à propos de l'imagerie, nous
ne continuerions pas à revenir à son travail et à l'
honorer ce soir
pour lui tout bat à tout moment
en commençant par l'histoire le personnage
et mille autres choses qui devaient
aller bien  pour qu'une seule image fasse
partie de son film
si c'est à un degré, cela pourrait aussi bien
être à 180 degrés il n'y a pas presque il n'y
a pas presque il n'y a pas assez près
son idée du professionnalisme est la plupart
des autres idée d'obsession
travailler avec lui vous  saura ce que
ressent Excellence et comme il le dit si
nous ne jonglons pas avec des tronçonneuses, nous
nous rendons un mauvais service
parce que les films parlent d'eux-mêmes, alors
voici quelques faits amusants sur Fincher euh il faisait
partie de sa première série House of
Cards euh il était  l'un des
décideurs à décider de publier toute la
saison à la fois en changeant la façon dont nous voyons
euh notre série
alias la frénésie de regarder ce bouton de saut d'intro
au premier à tous les streamers
ont également adopté Fincher et vous savez
cette carte de rôtisserie que vous verrez  quand
les acteurs dégringolent à l'intérieur d'une
carte renversante,
yep Venture deux
maintenant, mon Hollywood aime utiliser le mot
génie, mais les malentendus sont souvent de
vrais génies que
nous qui avons eu la chance de rouler dans
son sillage vous diront qu'il est chaud un
gros softy
qui est incroyablement articulé  et
rigoureusement honnête et prend grand soin
d'expliquer sa vision,
nous essaierons de décrire la sagesse de la perle
qui tombe de sa bouche, mais
nous ne réussirons pas à
vous dire qu'il est le plus dur avec
lui-même
et même s'il est le gars le plus intelligent de
la pièce, il est lui-même  - dépréciant et le
[ __ ] le plus drôle que nous ayons jamais rencontré,
il est fidèle à l'os et à notre tour, nous
rampons joyeusement à travers le verre pour lui et
lui demandons une autre prise,
ce ne sont là que quelques-unes des choses que nous
pourrions dire à propos de cet homme qui signifie
tellement  pour nous,
ma vie a changé à jamais un jour en
94 lorsque je me suis assis pour un café avec
David Fincher
Je ne sais pas si ce que nous faisons
compte à la fin ce que je sais que ce qui
compte, ce sont les gens avec qui nous nous attachons
et  la Marque indélébile qu'ils laissent sur
notre être même
Je lisais un passage récemment où un
personnage demandait quel est le plus
important le voyage ou la destination
et l'autre a répondu que c'est la compagnie
et je ne pouvais pas être plus d'accord
[Applaudissements]
merci
vous bénisse
merci pour votre merveilleuse invitation
et
je dois dire que
cela m'a pris par surprise parce que les films que
je fais ont tendance à être un peu épineux
euh et toute discussion qui commence par
votre travail ne peut s'empêcher d'évoquer des
images d'hospice
alors j'ai délibéré avec  des amis proches qui sont
tous arrivés à la même conclusion lorsque
des gens qui se soucient profondément de la qualité
de l'art littérature photographie mode
architecture nourriture vin et cinéma
vous demandent de venir célébrer vous allez
Je me tiens ici représentant littéralement le
travail acharné de milliers de personnes
tout en étant assis à proximité  regarder la télévision
donc je dois maintenant les remercier profondément pour l'
honneur
et je salue la culture du
cinéma français le métier et la critique
Je salue votre engagement pour un cinéma
qui reflète qui nous sommes dans notre plus petit
et plus simple et pas seulement nos
aspirations héroïques une fois que nous  avoir nos
collants sur
l'art de la peinture a des milliers d'
années et le cinéma un peu plus de cent ans,
nous commençons seulement à gratter la
surface de son potentiel j'espère
vous revoir un jour dans son avenir encore plus
glorieux
et enfin je tiens à reconnaître  ma femme
et ma fille qui sont mon phare quand je suis
perdu dans les ronces de l'
auto-récrimination créative et seule leur
gentillesse me ramène à la maison
merci beaucoup